say 585 pages but also an incredibly
important document for the future
relationship of the UK with the EU and
on our future rules and regulations one
of the key things we've been talking
about is set out here in this joint
statement about the draft withdrawal
agreement containing this protocol that
the Northern Ireland would have a
legally operative backstop including a
single customs territory between the
European Union and the United Kingdom
now it says that neither the EU or the
UK wants this to enter into force but if
it does what does it mean well if we go
into the main document we can see that
it actually means different rules and
regulations for Northern Ireland in
certain areas to the rest of the United
Kingdom so there would be more EU law in
agriculture in the environment the
electricity market state aid and also
v80 and excise that would be regulated
differently in Northern Ireland to the
rest of the United Kingdom how are those
regulations be applied well I think this
statement will alarm some people
particularly the brexit ears the union
representatives shall have the right to
be present during and receive upon
request all relevant information
relating to any activities of the United
Kingdom authorities related the
implication applications of provisions
under union law made available by this
protocol so the United Kingdom shall
facilitate the presence of union
representatives and provide them with
information requested and if they want
certain measures put in place then the
UK authorities are obliged to put those
measures into place now how easy is it
to leave this is the big question if we
go into this backstop arrangement if at
any time under the under the end of the
transition period the Union or the
United Kingdom considers that the
protocol is working they have to
basically set out their reasons and
notify the joint committee now what it
says then is that I think this is really
the key bit that the Union and the
United Kingdom decide jointly within the
jointly Committee that the protocol in
whole or part is no longer necessary to
achieve its objectives so there is no
you
natural way for the United Kingdom to
get out of a backstop now that makes it
harder to leave this agreement than it
does to leave the EU if you imagine when
you want to leave the EU you've at least
got article 50 which you can you can
actually apply that unilaterally here
you have to get agreement one of the
other things I think that brexit ears
won't like is this this paragraph here
about judgments and orders of the
European Court of Justice which
basically says that if they're handed
down before the end of the transition
period they have a binding force in
their entirety on the United Kingdom now
let's just go back to that original
joint statement to end if we look at the
bottom of it here I think this is
another key issue on the issue of trade
and goods and negotiations have agreed
in principle for a comprehensive
Arrangements creating a free trade area
and combining deep regulatory and
customs cooperation building on the
single customs territory provided for in
their withdrawal agreement but both
sides whilst they wish for this trading
relation to be as close as possible it
talks about here balancing the rights
and obligations of the integrity of the
European single market in customs union
with the development of the United
Kingdom's independent trade policy and
that will be subject of the future trade
relationships that key issue about our
future trading relationship with the EU
has not been decided so ask all these
other things have been discussed and
decided and will be signed up and sealed
in this document agreement the key thing
that the UK is trying to negotiate with
Europe actually has not yet been decided
in this document